[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ressemble plus à laisser partir un
deux trois qu'est ce que vous pensez et
transports en commun parisiens alors de
façon très global extrêmement élevé au
niveau tarifaire par rapport au service
rendu
parce que plein de dysfonctionnements
votre salle en pense quoi
ma soeur je pense qu'elles sont bas et
mais complètement les steaks
non mais c'est vrai parce que vraiment
les transports après c'est vrai c'est
vraiment juste quand j'ai dansé avec les
stars le soir que voilà services des
deux bouchers donc j'y vais vite tu
avais sinon je te prends assez rarement
quoi ça va pas durer
ouais j'aime bien ouais j'ai après
restons belle j'ai trouvé je veux un
carton mais cartonne avec les pouilles à
fond les ballons sacs ou là par quoi tu
as un peu trop simple ouais mais ça des
gorges en contrebas très propre c'est
quand tu rentres dans l'est dans les
wagons à chaque fois ces crabes
ça dépend des stations mais des fois ça
pue maintenant c'est sûr que
c'est un peu galère parce que
souvent tu prends tu de moi vu que moi
je les prends super tôt le matin ou tard
le soir c'est galère bonjour ça roule
ouais c'est pourquoi c'est pour le
transport en commun parisiens pour celui
tour je trouve encore des transports en
commun mon pote chez du bifff moi c'est
ton frère ben c'est pas bon on n'est pas
sûr d'arriver à l'heure et c'est votre
heure on pense quoi très habile en pense
quoi
euh mon frère on est frères ouais c'est
le beau et la folle échappée le rebelle
quoi et les cristaux et une fois je
retiens la clé usb sans demander
l'autorisation prison break
j'ai l'impression qu'un peu de m
[Musique]